bienvenue dans un monde futuriste avec
ce documentaire réalisé par Jesse Picard
ou les machines qu'elle ressemble ou pas
à des hommes deviennent des compagnons
de vie ou des scientifiques s'efforce
vous venez de le voir de doter des
robots d'une part d'humanité au franc
par la même à leurs utilisateurs un
semblant de vie affectives ou de vie
sociale pourquoi un tel besoin quels
sont les raisons diverses qui poussent
désormais l'homme à vouloir concevoir
des humanoïdes nous allons en débattre
maintenant sur ce plateau de débat doc
en compagnie de nos invités en
commençant par vous serre-tisseron
bienvenue à vous bonjour vous êtes
psychiatre psychanalyste membre de
l'Académie des technologies et du
Conseil National du Numérique que vous
avez par ailleurs fondé voilà 10 ans
maintenant l'Institut pour l'étude des
relations homme robot vous êtes l'auteur
de ce livre le jour où mon robot mènera
vers l'empathie artificiel un ouvrage
publié chez Albin Michel et puis tout
récemment celui-ci
construisent insidieuses des machines
parlantes un livre publié lui chez les
liens qui libèrent également avec nous
Sophie Saka bienvenue à vous et vous
êtes professeur des universités à
l'Institut national supérieur de
formation et de recherche handicap et
enseignement adaptés vos recherches
portent justement sur la robotique
humanoïde et le mouvement humain vous
êtes par ailleurs fondatrice de
l'association robot on en reparlera tout
à l'heure mais son objectif est la
diffusion auprès du grand public de
connaissances et de compétences sur les
robots et leurs utilisations puis enfin
avec nous Catherine Simon bienvenue à
vous vous êtes experte de l'écosystème
robotique mondial et ancienne directrice
générale de la société
Robopolis vous êtes aujourd'hui
conseillère numérique industriel au
secrétariat général pour
l'investissement au sein de son pôle
souveraineté num et vous avez été la
co-auteur d'un rapport parlementaire
intitulé faire de la France un champion
international de robotique et système
intelligent état des lieux en jeu et
bien sûr dans ce rapport proposition
c'est un rapport que vous avez
coécrit avec le député l'ancien député
Bruno Bonnel ancien député la République
en marche du Rhône première question
elle tombe sous le sens après avoir vu
le film que nous avons regardé ensemble
pourquoi pourquoi les hommes
ces forces-t-il de créer des humanoïdes
de données des sensations des sentiments
au robot c'est pas aussi évident que ça
non mais c'est un vieux rêve de
l'humanité vous savez déjà les Grecs
imaginés qui Héphaïstos le dieu du feu
était accompagné de servante mécanique
alors à l'époque on parlait pas de
donner des émotions au robot mais
c'était le robot qui allait aider
l'humain dans ses tâches et pendant très
longtemps d'ailleurs on n'a pas envisagé
les autrement dans les rêveries des
années
1950-1980 il faut donner au robot la
possibilité de nous aider et puis en
effet cette nouveauté qui est de leur
donner des émotions vous savez il faut
se méfier de langage dans l'introduction
vous avez dit créer des émotions robots
non on leur donne la capacité de simuler
des émotions le problème c'est que quand
un robot est capable ou même une
enceinte connectée une boîte capable de
nous parler avec une certaine voix
triste ou aguicheuse ou séductrice et
ben on a tendance à la croire voilà et
donc si vous voulez la grande difficulté
ça va être de vivre avec des machines
qui simulent les compétences humaines
tout en gardant toujours à l'esprit que
elles ne font que simuler et là il y a
évidemment beaucoup de risques de dérive
de gens qui franchiront le pas et qui
oublieront que la machine simule et qui
croiront pour de vrai que les
compliments de la machine sont fondés
que les opinions de la machine sont
fondées que les conseils de la machine
sont fondés donc voyez c'est un énorme
problème comme c'est évoqué dans le film
parce que évidemment ces machines elles
vont nous être agréables mais en même
temps elles vont pouvoir nous influencer
bien au-delà de ce qu'on imagine il y
avait peut-être un petit côté
provocateur dans la présentation que
j'ai faite thématique du jour mais j'ai
bien compris qu'il fallait pas vous
parler de robots émotionnel parce que
pour vous ce sont des machines à simuler
tout ça voilà exactement ben alors ça
c'est pas une opinion personne là je
crois qu'on l'a partagé tous dans l'état
actuel de la technologie tout au moins
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
pourquoi ce besoin chez l'homme de de
vouloir absolument humaniser les robots
aujourd'hui
alors outre le vieux rêve qui a déjà été
c'est un challenge Sun challenge je
trouve que dans le reportage beaucoup
beaucoup de robots beaucoup d'humanoïdes
finalement est-ce qu'on va pas la
déshumaniser notre société vous voyez ce
que je dis dans le reportage les gens
qui interviennent sur la robotique si
vous avez remarqué ce sont des gens qui
sont concentrés sur le challenge
technologique principalement c'est à
dire il ne parle pas de projection ou de
prospection de l'usage de ces machines
dans nos quotidiens en fait et dans la
science-fiction dans les films qu'on
voit on voit ces machines et
l'interaction et ses machines comme si
elles étaient naturellement intégrées
dans la société humaine sans vraiment
réfléchir non plus à l'impact Cora cette
intégration parce qu'on peut pas en fait
on peut voir que dans la limite de notre
imaginaire donc
les essais devront être faits pour les
intégrer maintenant le pourquoi outre le
challenge technologie outre la
réalisation d'un vieux rêve qui consiste
alors certains diront à créer la vie
comme notre Créateur était le seul et le
seul normalement avoir ce pouvoir
il y a le c'est un aboutissement
technologique je pense aujourd'hui ne se
passe d'oeuvre d'art à l'échelle de
l'humanité
et ça c'est logique peut-être dans
l'esprit des scientifiques comme vous
qui travaillent sur ce sujet il y a un
challenge scientifique il y a de toute
façon le challenge c'est ce qui a été ce
qui a été réalisé déjà relève du
challenge quoi parce que le fait d'avoir
ces technologies enfin il y a beaucoup
d'exemples dans ce compte documentaire
c'est déjà un challenge et l'objectif
qu'on se met en tête c'est à dire d'être
en mesure de d'avoir une machine où on
n'est pas capable de distinguer si c'est
un homme ou si c'est un robot c'est un
humain ou c'est un robot homme ou femme
je trouve ça extraordinaire alors on y
va bien compris ce qui s'est dit dans ce
documentaire je sais que vous allez
travailler dans le cadre de vos de votre
formation de vos recherches au Japon et
on voit effectivement et c'est pas une
surprise dans ce documentaire qui sont
très en avant sur ce sujet très impliqué
les Asiatiques peut-être d'une manière
générale mais les Japonais en
particulier il y a une se passe là au
Japon le robot est une machine qui est
là pour faire rire l'homme pour le
divertir en fait donc il y a pas et
c'est pas forcément la même vision que
dans nos pays
il y a pas d'ambiguïté sur créature ou
création au Japon en fait c'est vraiment
une création de l'homme qui est faite
pour amuser l'homme en fait et si jamais
il y a des méchants robots dans ce
cas-là il y a des gens qui robots qui
vont protéger l'homme de il y aura
toujours un équilibre qui va se créer
mais il faut que le robot fasse partie
de l'environnement peut-être plus que
dans notre société occidentale
c'est plus facile en fait c'est plus
facile au Japon oui moi je pense que
c'est aussi une question de facilité
d'interface infinie parce que vous avez
alors très terre à terre on sait
interagir avec d'autres humains on n'est
pas forcément hyper doué à sur des
machines qui sont plus compliquées dans
leurs interfaces avec les claviers les
la réalité virtuelle la réalité
augmentée là on a un humanoïde en phase
c'est quelque chose qu'on connaît on
connaît à peu près les capacités de
marche de préhension un robot de ment
pas c'est ce qu'il dit dans ce film et
c'est ce qui semble
un des alors là un des arguments
justifient la mise en place de
mentir le programmeur peut mentir
et puis je pense qu'il y a aussi un côté
très culturel à l'acceptation des robots
autant au Japon c'est pas un problème le
robot est l'ami de l'homme autant
effectivement dans nos sociétés plus
européennes et française on n'est pas
aussi
aussi à proximité finalement de robot
notre boutique industrielle et
voilà peine peine à être très développé
et
du coup comme on n'est pas en
connaissance
et en connexion avec des machines
robotiques très souvent et ben on a
tendance à fantasmer en bien en mal donc
utopie et sans contraires dystopie donc
on a des imaginaires parce que qui sont
un peu déconnectés de la réalité de ce
qu'est un robot et je pense que ça ça
participe à
l'imaginaire de les robots qui
ressemblent des émotions oui alors
l'importance du langage et l'importance
des émotions c'est pas tout à fait
pareil le langage en effet c'est fait
pour avoir des interfaces beaucoup plus
simples sont plutôt que de programmer un
robot pour qu'il m'apporte une bouteille
c'est mieux de lui dire apporte-moi donc
la bouteille qui est dans le
réfrigérateur si il est capable de
comprendre le message mais ça veut pas
dire forcément qu'il va m'apporter la
bouteille avec un grand sourire et qui
va trouver l'intonation adaptée pour me
parler s'il me voit triste il me dira
voilà Monsieur la bouteille et si il me
voit joyeux me dire voilà la bouteille
vous demander les émotions c'est pour
créer une relation de confiance c'est
pas vraiment pour créer une relation de
coopération plus efficace et pour créer
une relation de confiance et il y a un
autre élément qui peut présent dans le
film et qu'on appelle l'attention
conjointe c'est le fait que un robot
soit capable non seulement de simuler
des émotions de comprendre nos émotions
nos simuler mais aussi de s'intéresser à
ce qui nous intéresse vous êtes dans la
relation sociale vous êtes dans la rue
vous voyez quelqu'un qui regarde en
l'air l'expérience a été faite souvent
il y a plein de gens qui se troupes qui
regardent en l'air que l'être humain a
tendance à imiter les comportements
qu'il voit en se disant c'est quelqu'un
fait quelque chose sans doute ça doit
avoir un sens je veux faire pareil puis
voir ce qui se produit et donc voilà
l'idée d'ajouter encore l'intention
conjointe robot sur si vous l'idée c'est
que si vous avez une personne âgée qui a
de la difficulté à parler qu'elle a soif
elle regarde son verre d'eau sur sa
table de nuit à côté d'elle et que le
robot comprenne par ce regard lui
regarde le verre d'eau aussi il comprend
que la dame a soif vous voyez donc en
fait on a le langage on a les émotions
on a l'intention conjointe et en fait
chaque fois on augmente d'un degré dans
la confiance qu'on porte à la machine
avec ce que ça positif ce que on vit
avec elle puisque ça problématique c'est
que la machine elle peut bugger et puis
comme l'évoquer Sophie Saka elle est pas
forcément programmée pour répondre
toujours à ce que nous voulons mais
aussi parfois ce que veut le programme
ce que veut le commerçant qui est la
commercialisent on va voir un extrait du
documentaire que nous venons de voir sur
justement cette question de la place des
robots humanoïdes
[Musique]
des robots humanoïdes comme cela
curiosité de la surprise voire même des
moqueries des réactions peut
souhaitables si on veut qu'il s'intègre
davantage auprès de l'homme
il faut donc doter ces machines de la
faculté d'exprimer des émotions
un enjeu pour de nombreux laboratoires
récemment moi j'avais peut-être l'idée
d'une compensation affective derrière
pour les utilisateurs notamment
association de soutien en matière de
lien social
un soutien peut-être ça dire le robot
sera toujours d'accord avec vous si il
est bien programmé enfin si il est
gentil ils vous soutiendra il vous dira
il vous fera les compliments dont vous
avez besoin il vous rassurera sur des
démarches puisque à chaque fois on a
dans la vie on peut être confronté à des
situations difficiles leur beau sera
toujours là pour soutenir de la comme le
ferait en fait un peu un parent de dire
mais si allez et cet encouragement est
parfois ce qui manque pour passer à
l'acte ou faire des choses dans la vie
le robot compagnon a été l'usage majeur
qui a été fait donc on imagine pour
animer des salons ce qui c'est ce qui
est fait actuellement faire de
l'animation on l'a utilisé pour
remplacer que je m'entraînais parce que
j'ai tellement lu que le mot est devenu
presque inhabituer de remplacer un
thérapeute dans le cadre thérapeutique
d'accompagnement d'autisme ou de
personnes
pour encourager des personnes par
exemple
dans les expériences
qui ont été faites dans les EHPAD ou
donc le robot companion qui va assister
va remplacer l'accompagnement permanent
qu'on ne peut pas forcément fournir aux
personnes ou qui permettent justement
d'établir un lien par exemple avec un
autiste qui a une affinité particulière
avec le robot d'accord dès qu'il y a un
robot la personne en situation de
troubles du spectre autistique est très
attiré par cette machine donc ça permet
d'établir un lien en fait en 2014 moi
j'avais placé un autre usage de ce robot
qui est une prothèse en fait avec le
monde c'est à dire c'est pas un
interlocuteur qu'on va solliciter ou qui
va nous solliciter mais c'est une
machine qui fonctionne comme une
béquille en fait c'est à dire qu'on va
pouvoir faire parler à notre place faire
agir à notre place de manière à faire
une médiation mais cette fois-ci on est
dans le dos du robot et on voit les
effets de cette interaction avec le
monde ce qui peut rassurer qu'on utilise
justement dans les programmes robotismes
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de
rajouter sur l'utilisation de
ces robot dans peut-être plus largement
la robotique l'humanoïde qu'est-ce qu'il
peut apporter de plus dans cet univers
de la robotique aujourd'hui alors pour
moi l'humanoïde c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est un peu l'interface
ultime parce que il est adapté à notre
monde c'est pas le monde qui s'adapte à
la machine au même titre que au moment
où on a eu les machines à laver linge au
départ on les avait mis dans les
cuisines parce qu'il y avait pas la
place dans les salles de bain puis après
on a agrandi les salles de bain parce
que finalement avoir son linge sale à
côté donc notre environnement s'est
adapté à des nouvelles machines
aujourd'hui on pense la robotique
humanoïde comme 100% adapté finalement à
notre monde réel d'aujourd'hui qui est
fait pour les pour les humains
bipède avec deux bras de main une tête
des yeux voilà après moi je pense qu'en
termes d'usage il faut faire attention
parce que oui le robot est toujours
d'accord avec moi et ça moi je trouve
que c'est quelque part
pas du lien social parce que le lien
social il se aussi par la différence il
se fait aussi par l'échange et la
discussion de de gens qui sont pas
d'accord avec vous et là moi je trouve
que c'est un biais
auquel il faut faire très attention que
cette machine ne soit pas finalement une
un renforcement de mes propres biais
j'ai toujours raison voilà et en termes
aussi l'habitude de penser que les
robots sont là pour éviter les tâches
les plus pénibles c'est le cas
évidemment dans l'industrialisation
évidemment
[Musique]
pour imaginer que des humanoïdes fassent
leur entrée demain pour justement ce
type de tâches
répétitif pénible etc ou est-ce que là
on n'a pas besoin d'humaniser un
robotise un peu les rebonds industriels
parce que du coup les par exemple leur
caméra qui sont souvent des caméras
vidéos doubles un peu comme des yeux et
puis ils ont malgré tout des bras soit
un seul et ça ressemble quand même un
brin même si eux ils ont 6 axes voilà
mais vous avez les robots à deux bras
qui ressemblent à des torse clairement
et la tête c'est juste la caméra pour la
perception etc non je pense que
la forme humanoïde elle est trompeuse
quand elle est quand elle est poussée à
son extrême quand c'est plus une
question de taille
et elle est pas obligatoire elle est
simplement pensée comme une interface si
je vous ai bien compris vous venez de
nous dire tout de même attention
attention
il faut pas se servir de de ces
humanoïdes pour pour des carences
affectives parce que là il y a peut-être
une limite à ne pas franchir vous êtes
d'accord avec ça alors d'abord j'aurais
quand même apporté une précision parce
qu'on a vu beaucoup de débats de robots
dans le documentaire par exemple les
robots qu'il y a dans un hôtel au Japon
alors on les appelle Android pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont une similitude
d'apparence avec un humain est encore
imparfaite mais ils ont un visage ça
s'arrête au tronc parce que dessous il y
a tout il y a informatique il y a de
l'informatique mais il y a des robots on
a vu d'autres robots qui ont deux bras
de jambes enfin de forme de bras de
forme de jambes forme de Tron et forme
de tête mais qui ne ressent pas du tout
un humain ou qui peuvent être petits
voilà comme le robonao et donc là on les
appelle André on les appelle humanoïdes
c'est humanoïde c'est le robot qui peut
avoir des fonctions humaines et Android
c'est le robot qui peut avoir une
apparence humaine et toute la question
c'est le savoir faut-il qu'un robot est
une apparence humaine pour nous rendre
des services est-ce que ça suffit pas
qu'il est simplement une similitude de
fonctionnalité de bras de jambes etc
puisse monter les escaliers par exemple
ça ça peut suffire à ce qui nous rendent
des grands services vous voyez donc il y
a tout un débat actuellement et les
Japonais en effet poussent les robots
Android qui ont une apparence humaine de
ce féminitude d'apparence avec un visage
en est là mais et en accident on est un
peu plus réticent ce genre de machine ce
que j'ai encore c'est que il y a
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire des machines de
ces robots alors dans les entreprises
c'est clair mais en dehors des utilis
pratique concrète voilà des chaînes de
montage et tout ça on en sait pas grand
chose parce que il y a très peu d'études
parce qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait des
robots introduits dans les familles pour
qu'on sache comment les familles vont
les gérer peut-être ça va être le coup
de faute peut-être au bout de trois mois
ils vont le mettre dans un placard on
n'en sait rien du tout donc voilà faut
avancer très prudemment sur les usages
d'ailleurs il y a régulièrement des
entreprises de robotique qui se cassent
la gueule parce que parce qu'elle
n'arrive pas à trouver le le créneau
dans lequel elles peuvent s'insérer je
reviens néanmoins sur le terrain
affectif oui dans ce documentaire on a
vu notamment Parrot dans un EHPAD c'est
un petit phoque qui a été commercialisé
depuis 2005 d'ailleurs au Japon et puis
maintenant il est remplacé ce petit
phoque par un robot aux allures plus
humaines qui s'appelle Zora c'est un
robot commercialisé par une société
belge qui s'appelle Zora bots dans ce
documentaire il y avait tout de même
des gains affectifs à attendre de la
présence de ce petit barreau là dans
cette EHPAD
la dimension affective la dimension du
lien social que peut créer la présence
de ce robot notamment dans les EHPAD
mais j'imagine pas seulement elle a
l'air avérée elle est avérée
statistiquement c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
des personnes qui ne supportent pas il y
a des personnes qui le supportent un peu
mais pas beaucoup il y en a qui en
bénéficient donc actuellement il y a
beaucoup de programme de recherche pour
savoir comment introduire la machine et
ce qu'on s'en aperçoit dont on
s'aperçoit finalement c'est que la
machine peut permettre de développer des
liens entre les personnes âgées mais
aussi entre les personnes âgées et le
personnel changé de s'en occuper et même
ces machines peuvent contribuer à créer
des liens entre les personnes chargées
de s'occuper des personnes âgées et
c'est là où c'est le plus intéressant
mais si vous voulez pour obtenir tout ça
il faut le chercher il faut qu'il y a un
accompagnement voilà ça fait pour en
parler mieux que moi il faut il faut
viser cet objectif là sans se contente
de se dire voilà un robot-paro ça va
augmenter la sociabilité des personnes
âgées on l'apporte on le pose on le pose
la table et on attend de voir ce qui se
passe c'est pas intéressant voilà donc
il y a tout un travail d'accompagnement
aujourd'hui et notre idée à l'Institut
pour l'étude de la chambre c'est quand
même que il faut utiliser les robots
dans la relation thérapeutique mais il
faut pas remplacer les thérapeutes par
des robots il faut utiliser ces machines
pour permettre aux thérapeute de faire
mieux plus efficacement peut-être
parfois plus rapidement ce que jusque là
il faisait sans machine mais c'est eux
qui continuent quand même à gérer les
indications comme on dit
traditionnellement deuxième extrait du
film que nous avons gardé ensemble
il concerne ces robots
ces humanoïdes
dans le marché du sexe
les poupées sexuelles font leur
apparition dans les années 1900 avec
l'invention du caoutchouc
depuis elle ne cesse de provoquer le
dégoût pour certains l'intérêt pour
d'autres
aujourd'hui les avancées technologiques
vont permettre de satisfaire les désirs
les plus fous des utilisateurs
[Musique]
alors le marché du sexe lui a trouvé des
utilisations pour ces robots que l'on
voit dans le film bon qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en dire
une surprise pour vous que ce marché se
développe les objets sexuels existent
depuis longtemps je pense c'est pas une
découverte ça maintenant qui sont les
bonnes vieilles poupées gonflables
pardonnez-moi
le sexe normalement
là on est dans une amélioration du
recharge du plaisir c'est à dire avoir
la température corporelle avoir le
ressenti de de
partager quelque chose en fait avec avec
une personne selon les avantages qui
nous sont propres dans une intimité
qu'on a parfois soit pas l'habitude de
partager ou plus plus l'habitude
peut-être de partager ou plus l'envie je
ne sais pas
l'excitation
c'est pas quand vous êtes avec une
personne
c'est pas moi que ce soit une personne
professionnelle mais normalement vous
avez quand même des phases avant après
autour enfin tout un habillage en fait
émotionnel de l'acte sexuel que là
vous vous dénudez finalement cet acte
pour que les gens bénéficient de la base
du ressenti de plaisir et pour que le
plaisir se ressente mieux et bien le
contexte un espèce de contexte est mis
en place on l'a vu aussi avec la réalité
virtuelle par exemple donc avec vous
vous êtes projeté dans un univers
carrément un environnement qui est
érotique et qui vous permet de prendre
un plus grand plaisir donc la recherche
ici c'est la recherche d'amélioration du
plaisir le marché a toujours existé
alors le marché est toujours existé mais
l'industrie du sexe a l'air de profiter
de ces
progrès du côté de la robotique en
dehors de l'idée de faire attention à
pas de confusion entre le vrai humain et
le robot sexuel
tant mieux que pour plus de plaisir ayez
des technologies qui puissent être
intégrées à ces traditionnel poupée
gonflable après voilà toujours en disant
bien c'est comme
c'est la base on est sur la base on
n'est pas dans le lien social on n'est
pas dans le lien intime on est dans la
simulation et et elle est plus
travaillée
du psychiatre sur ce sujet particulier
alors actuellement c'est une niche
qu'est-ce que ça deviendra dans l'avenir
on sait trop pas voilà si on était tous
confinés sans pouvoir se déplacer vous
savez des gens qui ont recours aux
plateformes de rencontres ont été très
malheureux pendant le confinement donc
ils avaient besoin de substitut donc
qu'est-ce que ça deviendra dans la durée
on sait pas trop ce qui est certain
c'est que les fabricants
veulent apporter beaucoup de
perfectionnement pour créer au moins une
illusion de relations sexuelles pendant
la durée de la relation sexuelle après
comme des Sophie il y a des gens qui
peuvent en ville d'un avant d'un après
etc de préliminaire etc donc je pense
que là où ça va être le plus intéressant
ça va être la manière dont ces poupées
vont être intégrées à des pratiques
sexuelles entre humains c'est à dire non
pas un humain un des deux partenaires
remplacés par une poupée sexuelle mais
deux partenaires avec une poupée
sexuelle ou un partenaire ou deux
partenaires avec deux poupées sexuelles
ou quatre partenaires avec une
professeur et puis des poupées sexuelles
qui seront pas forcément ressemblantes à
des vraies créatures humaines mais après
tout on peut aussi fabriquer des poupées
sexuelles qui soient exubérante qui
qui correspondent aux rêveries une
certaine personne des 5 gigantesques des
fessiers monstrueux enfin voilà je pense
que ce qui va être intéressant c'est de
voir comment des désirs humains qui
jusque là n'arrivent pas à satisfaire
dans la réalité vont pouvoir satisfaire
avec des machines avec toujours le
risque évidemment que plus on
s'intéresse au machine qu'on commence à
s'intéresser aux machines parce qu'on se
détourne des humains et puis on se
rapproche des machines et puis on risque
d'être tourné des humains
quels sont les nouveaux objectifs les
nouvelles frontières
des recherches scientifiques en cours en
matière
d'humanoïde d'émotions chez les robots
pour poursuivre le sujet qui qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui moi je travaille
sur les usages à l'analyse d'impact donc
ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est quand on je
commence vraiment à travailler quand on
oublie que c'est une machine en face
c'est-à-dire dans l'interaction
naturelle par exemple typiquement
l'expérience qu'ils ont fait à Marseille
de parler avec un humain et de parler
avec un robot nous on l'a fait avec un
danseur dose complet c'est à dire un
opérateur humain qui était instrumental
d'une capture du mouvement la voix qui
est envoyé au robot et qui recevait les
images du robots et le son autour du
robot donc était en immersion totale
opération ce qu'on appelle l'opération à
distance
en train de discuter avec un
interlocuteur humain et donc cette
interlocuteur humain qui était des
citoyens qui ont été bénévoles pour le
volontaire pour le test on discutait
donc 15 minutes avec une femme qu'il ne
connaissait pas
ils ont fait un test de personnalité ils
ont fait discuter 15 minutes avec un
homme qui ne connaissait pas test de
personnalité et 15 minutes avec un robot
qui ne connaissait pas test de
personnalité au début de l'expérience il
ne savait pas que c'était un humain
c'est-à-dire ils ont on leur a juste dit
que c'est une intelligence artificielle
comme comme dans le reportage
et ils ont fait ce donc ce test on l'a
fait de manière assez rigoureuse pour
voir un petit peu la différence de
relation avec le robot
donc est-ce à la fin bien sûr on leur
disait quand même il partait pas comme
ça en étant persuadé qu'ils avaient
parlé avec une créature artificielle
donc le lien est normal naturel c'est
pas plus naturel c'est un humain qui
était derrière donc la discussion s'est
instaurée entre l'homme et la machine la
très grosse différence qu'on peut voir
de comportement par rapport aux
démonstrations qu'on a sur les stands
actuels qui sont très limitées en termes
d'interaction parce que là c'était notre
échange naturel c'est déjà on a très
envie de parler avec ces machines on a
envie que ça marche ça marche comme dans
les films c'est à dire on a envie de les
voir fonctionner donc c'est pour ça
qu'on va vers et quand on voit qu'elle
ne répond pas à cette attente on s'en
détourne très rapidement avec une
déception en un temps beaucoup beaucoup
de la robotique humanoïdes alors que
effectivement en termes d'usage infini
on n'a pas besoin d'une sophistication
humanoïde on n'a pas besoin de multiples
capteurs enfin on a vraiment pas besoin
moins de ça pour avoir des usages
vraiment utiles en société ben voilà par
où c'est un phoque c'est pas un humain
et ça marche très bien chez mes parents
j'ai un robot de téléprésence et il est
pas du tout humanoïde c'est c'est de
manger à balai sur une base mobile avec
une une
tablette au dessus on croirait que ça
serait la même chose qu'une tablette sur
roulette mais pas du tout parce que ça
donne cet effet de présence moi je sais
que la première fois que j'ai utilisé ce
robot de téléprésence chez mes parents
mon père 90 ans donc il est allé fermer
la porte à clé vérifier que la porte
d'entrée était fermée à clé alors que le
robot est à l'intérieur on le met dans
une pièce à part pour pas être intrusif
et puis prévenir quand on se connecte au
robot mais pour autant et ben du coup on
peut avoir une conversation un peu plus
comme si on était là on n'est pas le nez
devant l'écran ils sont ainsi etc donc
je pense qu'il n'a pas besoin d'une
sophistication humanoïde pour aller dans
les usages c'est bien le challenge
technologique et ça nous permettra
peut-être effectivement en développant
cette romantique humanoïde on développe
de la robotique mobile sur des escaliers
sur des terrains accidentés sur des
terrains extérieurs on développe des
prothèses
robotiques d'ailleurs on développe plein
de technologies qui sont utiles à
l'homme l'homme lui-même et qui sont
quelque part simplifiées dans le
développement de technologie manoïdes
mais je pense on parle beaucoup des
chats de but aujourd'hui
vous pouvez peut-être nous en dire un
peu plus parce que ça ça semble tout de
même une forme d'intelligence
artificielle interactive entre un robot
et un homme
qui semble gagner du terrain alors le
chatbot déjà c'est pas un robot pour moi
le chatbot c'est l'intelligence
artificielle c'est du programme logiciel
le robot il faut que vous ayez une
partie perception quand même perception
de son environnement une partie analyse
et là vous avez là toute la partie
logicielle et une partie actionneur donc
une partie action sur le monde physique
réel c'est ce qu'on appelle un système
cyber physique numérique et physique
donc un chatbot il y a pas de physique
donc après les dialogues des chatbots
aujourd'hui s'améliorent tout le temps
enfin je sais pas si vous avez essayé le
l'échange et le langage le
soir
des scénarios après
préenregistrés ça vous amène voilà ça
éventuellement ça vous donne de l'aide
en vocal au lieu de vous donner de la
texture je sais pas s'il faut essayer
quel est le dernier truc de openia et
qui est une société plus la technologie
la plus avancée sur ce ben oui
globalement le web jusqu'en 2021
absolument tout le contenu du web depuis
vous posez n'importe quelle question à
tchatche et donc ils ont répondu oui
alors ils ont réponse à tout
statistiquement en fonction de à partir
de quels infos avec nos biais de bulles
etc donc il faut quand même faire
attention à comment on interroge une
intelligence artificielle et sur quoi on
l'interroge si je l'interroge et ce que
je dois marier avec cette personne
franchement c'est pas une machine qui
donne le dire la conversation le langage
ça c'est un domaine particulièrement
sensible dans ce domaine semble-t-il la
fluidité de la conversation qu'on peut
avoir avec un échangeur vocal par
exemple oui ça ça semble un domaine
particulièrement
riche pour l'avenir oui
mais je voudrais rebondir ce que un
Catherine il y a quand même des gens qui
demandent à l'horoscope ou à la diseuse
de Bonaventure ils doivent se rapprocher
telle personne ou pas donc je veux dire
il y a quand même chez l'être humain le
sentiment que la vie est trop compliquée
il faut constamment choisir et donc du
coup si on a une machine Ben qui peut
nous donner des conseils elle nous dira
bien sûr je ne donne que des conseils
mais on sera tenté de les suivre parce
que on se dira pourquoi pas aller dans
le sens de magie mais j'ai pas de raison
d'aller contre non plus j'ai pas de
raison d'aller au sens qu'elle dit mais
comme elle m'en parle j'ai dans ce sens
là alors effectivement pour que ça soit
efficace il faut que le chatbot il est
une proximité avec l'homme si la machine
parle avec une voix très mécanique comme
dans les films de science-fiction des
années 1950 va vous vous n'adhérez pas
ce qu'elle dit d'où l'importance en
effet de la capacité du chatbot à imiter
des émotions humaines et pouvoir
comprendre vos émotions et vous répondre
avec des émotions adaptées pas forcément
d'ailleurs les mêmes peut-être si vous
mettez en colère contre le chatbot le
chatbot va pas se mettre en colère
contre vous peut-être vous parler très
calmement vous voyez ou si vous dites
des énormités peut-être que le chatbot
va se mettre en colère parce qu'il sera
programmé pour ça donc là on retrouve
quelque chose qui est familier à la
communication humaine c'est que parfois
il est symétrique on va dans le même
sens puis parfois elle est
complémentaire donc il y a beaucoup de
travaux en effet pour rendre pour
permettre aux machines d'avoir ces deux
aspects de la communication humaine à
partir de là dans quelle place elles
vont prendre dans nos vies elles peuvent
en prendre beaucoup parce que on sait
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui
interagissent avec des humains qui ne
connaissent pas parmi les humains il y a
parfois des robots mais qui s'expriment
mal on les repères vite mais appartenant
un robot sera capable de faire la
conversation de rebondir sur ce que vous
dites probablement il y a un marché
considérable avec le risque évidemment
que la machine toujours n'oublions pas
le programmeur derrière plus orienter
vos choix d'une façon qui arrange le
programme un requier arrange le groupe
politique le groupe économique le groupe
logique dont le programmeur fait partie
vous avez raison de le redire et
d'insister sur ce sujet il y a toujours
un homme derrière une artige une
intelligence artificielle derrière une
machine l'homme qui croit parler à la
machine par la réalité toujours à
l'homme qui est derrière la machine
on approche à la fin de cette émission
oui
c'est peut-être une des failles
actuellement robotique il faudrait
absolument accompagner pour mettre les
populations en sécurité pour pour les
monter en compétences qu'elles soient en
mesure de se protéger justement de ces
phénomènes on arrive à la toute fin de
cette émission là on a vu beaucoup il y
a beaucoup d'expérimentations pour
passer à des échelles plus importantes
plus industrielles il faut avoir de
l'aide il faut avoir le soutien alors
pourquoi pas de l'état de société privée
c'est le cas aujourd'hui il y a une
véritable volonté d'investir dans
l'intelligence d'investir financièrement
dans ces fameux robots aujourd'hui par
exemple en France alors il y a deux
questions là il y a les robots et
l'intelligence alors dans les robots oui
il y a beaucoup d'investissement qui ont
été faits même récemment même dans les
écoles ou enfin dans les accompagnements
par contre une réflexion globale sur les
usages il y en a pas en fait
actuellement c'est le c'est totalement
libre le reportage a l'air de mentionner
aussi un point qui est assez important
c'est à dire comme si le robot pouvait
être une solution
à l'isolement alors là je suis pas
d'accord du tout c'est il y a des gens
qui ont un ressenti d'isolement déjà
c'est pas l'isolement c'est le ressenti
d'isolement ils peuvent avoir une vie
sociale très riche le robot n'est pas
une solution le robot les aide à
l'accepter ce qui est complètement
différent en fait donc ils sont toujours
isolés toujours seul mais le robot le
reprend à accepter ça c'est pas pareil
voilà donc après l'aide de l'État est
particulièrement enfin le c'est pas
l'aide il y a des aides il y a des
volontés mais le passage à l'acte est
particulièrement mal accompagné et aussi
peut-être par manque d'experts sur le
terrain
c'est tout neuf il y a peu de recul sur
la technologie et on ne connaît pas
encore l'impact faut de recul il
faudrait cadrer les usages
par des gens de terrain en fait sur le
terrain pour être sûr d'utiliser ces
machines de la bonne manière de manière
optimale pour certains je pense aux
handicap à l'accompagnement à la fête
justement pour des gens sentent mieux et
de vérifier qu'il y ait pas un effet
inverse parce que quand vous arrivez en
20h socialiser par exemple des personnes
en situation de troubles du spectre
autistique est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous désocialiserez par la
même technologie en 20h aussi des
personnes qui n'étaient pas qui
n'avaient pas ces problèmes et là il
faut qu'on ait du recul alors on va pas
expérimenter bien sûr on va passer on va
pas essayer mais il faut qu'on voit un
petit peu le contour de la machine c'est
capacités sur l'esprit humain et comment
le ne pas avoir de retour de bâton par
la suite ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc aujourd'hui
pour parler de la robotique et plus
particulièrement de cette volonté un des
hommes peut produire et d'alimenter des
humanoïdes aujourd'hui dans notre
société vos réactions j'imagine qu'elles
seront assez nombreuses aujourd'hui ça
sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter merci
à sel massali qui comme à l'accoutumée
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission moi
je vous donne rendez-vous pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]